(intro music)
- What it do chat.
My name is Ross Pineda, chef
and owner of Fire Kitchen.
And welcome to another episode
of Celebrity Recipe Royale.
On today's epis^ode, we're
going to be battling out
two celebrity breakfast sandwich recipes.
On today's lineup we have Gordon Ramsey
and BTS's very own J-Hope.
I measured out all the
ingredients as each recipe stated
and I found three
breakfast sandwich fanatics
to help me find out which one is the best.
Now which one of these
celebrities has the best sandwich.
Let's get it cracking.
Coming up (indistinct)
first is Gordon Ramsey.
He's going to start off
by slicing his croissants in half
and he's going to go
ahead and heat up a pan,
throw in a little bit of
oil and salt for seasoning.
Once you Brown up your salt a little bit
we're going to go ahead
and toast our croissants.
Since the croissants have so
much butter in them already,
the salt is going to add that
little bit of extra flavor.
Once the croissants are done toasting
we're going to put that to the side
and start working on the meat.
In Gordon Ramsay's recipe,
he uses taso ham, since we
ain't got that in Queens
he says, it's okay to use
Canadian bacon as a substitute.
So we're going to go ahead
and slice our Canadian bacon
into thin strips and fry them off.
Be careful not to add too much oil
since Canadian bacon
already has some fat in it.
Be careful when you're
cooking your Canadian bacon
because if you overcook it,
it will be tough and nobody
want to be eating jerky,
you know what I mean?
So we're going to saute
that for a little while.
We're going to flip it so
we can get some nice color,
once that's done we're going
to transfer that to a paper
laying in bowls so you
can drain the fat from it.
We trying to shed that Covid
weight you know what I mean?
I'm trying to look good baby.
In that same pan, you want to
throw in a little bit of oil
and a little bit of butter so
that the butter don't burn.
We're going to throw in
some salt and old bay
which is Gordon Ramsey's
secret weapon in this recipe.
We're going to crack two eggs in
and let the residual
heat cook off the eggs.
So now that your eggs are
cooking to the side slowly,
we're going to go ahead
and build our sauce.
By the way, I forgot to
season the Canadian bacon
with a little bit of peps in the pan
but I'm going to go ahead
and season in the bowl,
it's still fine.
In a bowl, we're going to
take a couple of heaping
tablespoons of mayo, a couple heavy dashes
of your favorite hot sauce.
We're going to take this
ginormous lemon and squeeze it
in to make the sauce tangy,
spicy and very saucy.
I like sauce.
Next step we're going to
slice up our (indistinct).
So we're going to go ahead and
thinly slice some tomatoes,
and we're going to go
ahead and cut some lettuce.
Make sure to take off the
(indistinct) from the lettuce
because it's kind of
weird in the sandwich.
Now that your (indistinct)
are sliced into the side
we're going to go ahead and base our egg.
So we want to just set the egg white and
base the yolk a tiny bit.
You still want to have that
nice, you know, yolk porn.
You want to pop that later on.
So now we're going to go
ahead and build our sandwich.
We're going to take the
bottom half of the croissant
put a little bit of sauce on the bottom.
Put on our lettuce, a little
bit of salt in between,
tomato, little bit of salt
in between Canadian bacon.
We're going to go about
six or seven slices.
We're going to fold in our cheddar cheese.
Next, we're going to top
that off with our very
nicely cooked egg, some
more sauce, and finally
the croissant top. Bang,
bang. There you have it.
Cajun style breakfast
sandwich by Gordon Ramsey.
We're going to close in
on that sexy egg and watch that yolk pop.
- All right baby.
Oh my guy.
This is made with a croissant.
- So my initial reaction to this one is
I love a good croissant.
- Little bit of a soggy bottom here,
but I will say the layers look delicious.
- And look at the sauce on.
This has got a lot of sauce.
- I don't like tomato though.
So I'm going to be rude
and take off the tomato.
- Cheese, yes. Egg, yes. Meat, yes.
- This is the way to go when it comes to
breakfast sandwiches, for real.
- I would have liked to see
maybe some sort of potato layer.
- To take a bite. I'm
going to take a bite.
(crunching)
- Mm.
- Mm, oh yeah, Hmm-mm.
- Holy cow, that's next
level breakfast stuff.
- That's delicious.
And we got a nice little runny yolk
on the egg, which is great.
- Honestly, the fact
that it's on a croissant
I think just elevates the whole thing.
It takes it out of this world.
- Some (indistinct) would have been nice
but I love the flavor.
The sauce is amazing.
- We have some sort of Chipotle mayonnaise
or some sort of pot mayonnaise going on
which I am a sucker for a spicy mayo.
- It's also got like that
juice from the tomato
that worked very well with the bacon
the sauce, everything wrapped up together.
- Overall, very good.
I would eat this breakfast sandwich again.
- This is definitely something that I feel
like I would find it
a more high end place.
- I would get this at a nice brunch,
I'm guzzling down some mimosas.
This is just kind of to fill my stomach
so I don't get too tipsy.
- This is going to be hard to beat
but I think it's time to
bring in the next one.
- [Ross] All right.
So next up in the ring
we have J-Hope from BTS.
He's going to take two slices
of bread and lather them up
with some butter.
He's going to take that, put
it in a slightly oiled pan
and toast them up real nice.
Make sure your butter is room
temp so you can lather it
up evenly and not break
your bread like I did.
Once the bread is nicely toasted.
We're going to transfer
that to a plate and
start cooking off our bacon.
You want to make your bacon extra crispy,
like you've been in the sun too
long with no tanning lotion.
All right, while your bacon
is in the pan crispin up,
we're going to go ahead
and whisk a couple of eggs.
Make sure your flip your bacon.
You want that nice all over even tan.
You want to drain some
of the fat from the bacon
but we're also going to cook the eggs
in the remaining bacon fat.
After you get a nice scramble,
you're going to transfer that
to a plate and we're
going to start building
J-Hope's golden sandwich.
So we're going to start off
by adding some extra butter.
We're going to go ahead and
throw on some blueberry jam.
That's actually his favorite,
then were gonna go ahead and
layer on some slices of bacon,
and to top it off, your
fluffy golden scrambled egg.
And there you have it.
The most attractive member
on BTS's golden toast.
Fight me on that one.
- Now right off the bat.
This is looking pretty breakfastee.
- I'm very excited about
this breakfast sandwich
because I see jam.
- I don't know how I feel about this.
It looks like a Blackberry jam maybe.
- In Korea there's this
like viral street sandwich
that has egg, cabbage, spam, but also jam.
I love that combination.
- Sweet and salty always a good mix.
- It smells maplely, I like that.
- Time to take a bite baby.
(upbeat music)
- Yup. It's so good.(laughs)
- Mm.
- Not gonna lie, this one
was a little surprising
cause it looks kind of elementary.
- I'm not going to lie, I enjoyed that a
lot more than I thought I was going to.
- This just makes me happy.
- The sweetness of the jam
with the bacon and the egg
is actually really balanced
and it's quite delicious.
- The bacon is just the
right amount of crisp.
- That fluffy egg on the top, stuff.
This is a good little
breakfast sandwich here.
- I'm really vibing with this whole jam.
I was suspicious of the jam at first.
I didn't think I was going to like the jam
but I'm vibing with the jam.
- [Ross] Now which one
of these celebrities
has the best sandwich.
Let's find out.
- People, this is a super tough decision.
And that being said
I'm going to go with
number one, final answer.
The croissant just really
just took it next level.
The sauce, the quality of
the bacon and everything.
All-in-all, it had to
be the one. who's is it?
Gordon Ramsey.
Again. I think I've picked Gordon Ramsey
the last three times now, but
my man does not disappoint.
Call me Ramsey(laughs).
- My favorite breakfast
sandwich of the two
would be number two.
It just brought a smile to my face.
And it did remind me a lot
of like the street
sandwiches back in Korea.
So definitely number two. Who is it?
Oh my God. (laughs)
J-Hope.
Ah, I love that.
- Out of these two
celebrity sandwich recipes,
I've got to say my favorite
was surprisingly number two.
I didn't think I was going to like jam
on a breakfast sandwich, but
it was actually delicious.
It was unexpected and I really enjoyed it.
Who made it?
Okay. Well that's cool. I love BTS.
I love K-pop. I like to
see artists go outside
of their usual area of
expertise. So I'm here for it.
- [Ross] Well, breakfast is K-pop
and cause J-Hope takes today's
Celebrity Recipe Royal.
So what other celebrities
do you guys want to see
enter the Celebrity Recipe Royale arena.
Leave a comment below.
(outro music)